there is certainly a school of thought
that um william
and kate were not happy at the way in
which
um these royal rock stars um
harry and megan overshadowed them and
that they're quite happy now to see them
out of the country that's one of the
reasons people close to the scene
doubt whether there'll be a
reconciliation because you know it's the
old syndrome this town is too small for
both of us
so first of all it's called battle of
the brothers um
and you say that this feud between
william and harry
is worse than people thought why so
yes it's it's it i think every day makes
clear that it's
it's worse than people thought and
certainly it goes back
way before people realized i mean one of
the
one of the objectives of the book is to
go back into the past
of these two boys into their childhoods
to see the way in which their lives were
shaped
cruelly really by the breakdown of their
parents marriage
and by the the royal roles and
distortion
that was placed upon them actually when
they were born it was william who was
the
rumbustious character it was harry was a
good little boy who sucked his stuff
um then william discovers that he's
going to be king he becomes much more
serious and quiet we're talking about
the age of six or seven
harry goes the other way there's a
famous story about he was in the back of
the car at the age of four
his nanny told him to behave and he said
i don't have to behave i'm not going to
be king
so already as children
their roles are being shaped for them
uh in his teenage years harry becomes
aware of this
um both he and william get into
oh let's not say trouble but um into
wild times at parties
harry in fact um was caught taking drugs
he notoriously was caught dressed in a
nazi uniform
you say that william had a little more
to do with choosing that costume than we
know
as the public when they went to a
costume party
they both went together to the costume
shop harry chose the nazi uniform
of a storm trooper william approved
apparently
william chose himself a nice safe
leopard or lion costume
they go home laughing they go to the
party laughing
um but when uh the story comes out
um it is harry who gets the blame um
and william escapes scott friend
and this is the first time we discover
conflict between the brothers harry
starts resenting the stereotype
that is forced upon him court jester
you know william is the king of the
castle he's the dirty rascal
and when kate comes along he happily
falls
into the role of number three fits in
so far so good and then he falls in love
with megan
and that really turns things around and
she makes him see things
in a new way so is that where the rift
really started with william and harry
when he saw how deep he was falling in
love with megan so
quickly i would say that there were
stresses and strains there before
and then with the advent of megan
um that was what provoked
the really big break william let us not
forget
um he made his girlfriend wait nine
years
before they married because he wanted
weighty katie to be sure
she would be happy as queen whereas
william
from all the turmoil of their childhood
took strength from the idea of his duty
and what lay ahead for him as king harry
cottoned on to the importance of love
they were the product of a loveless
arranged marriage
he was going to go for love so when he
found megan
he went for that and when william said
to him look
um perhaps you should slow down a bit
um harry exploded william then went to
his uncle
charles who is diana's brother um who'd
been a sort of godfather henry godfather
to the boys
and asked him to intervene and and tell
suggest to harry that he slowed down um
and harry rejected williams model he
knew what he wanted
he loved this woman um and he was going
to marry her so that was
certainly the beginning of the rift
there are numerous occasions when in
recent times the two brothers have lost
their temper
with each other it's been quite well
known that that
harry has a volatile temper
uh as i started writing the book a lot
of people close to the scene would say
well you know that william has a temper
as well
so we have two um emotionally damaged
young men
here it's so interesting to hear you
talk about
williams temper because from the outside
looking in to the public
we do get this picture painted that
harry's a little rambunctious
and doing his own thing and that william
is very much
regimented and that he's very even
healed and that he's
like cool as ice william is as cool as
ice
and william is building himself and kate
um into models of the perfect future
sovereigns for britain
but we know at the beginning of this
year
the big row exploded in the royal family
about harry and megan's plans to go and
live
in canada the queen said all right we'll
have a meeting next monday afternoon
two o'clock we'll sit down you bring all
your advisors we'll hash something out
um and before that we'll have a lunch
you know to
to talk his family and one of the
brothers
said no and which brother was there that
was william it wasn't harry
harry went to the lunch you wrote that
um william
was really ticked off about the details
of archie's christmas
why was he so upset about that
uh there's a tradition in um british
royal history
that um the newborn baby especially any
baby that is close to the line of the
throne
should be shown to the public and harry
and megan
both said no we want our new baby to be
born
in privacy and decency we're not going
to parade him to the public they already
had their um their hostility
uh towards the press um they said no
we're not parading for the public
we will show archie in good time and
they did two days later
so that was the background to that row
over the fact that
archie was not shown to the public as
william
showed all his babies when they were
born
when archie was born doria megan's
mother was actually there or close and
we know
that within a few days the queen and
prince philip although he is went round
to see the new baby for some reason
uh william and kate took eight days
before they visited archie
and then unlike normal practice they
didn't bring their own children
to meet their little cousin um
we don't know the details of that but it
is um
it's one of the signs of behavior that
we have to decipher
in the british royal family it's very
interesting that
the only one of the two who has publicly
acknowledged
a break um although of course he is
living an ocean and a continent
apart from his brother is is harry um
who you know
in in his um in his interview last year
in africa
he said we're going our separate ways
but he also said you know i will always
be there for my brother
um uh just as he will be for me
um but what's interesting is that
william has never said
anything like that william has actually
never
publicly acknowledged that there is a
riff
you